okay awesome
um we're going to get started
so uh my name is Jesse moo I'm a PhD
student in the Cs Department here uh
working with the NLP group and really
excited to be talking about the topic of
today's lecture
which is on prompting instruction
fine-tuning and rlhf so this is all
stuff that has been you know
um super hot recently because of all the
latest chick craze about chat Bots uh
chat gbt Bing Etc and we're going to
hopefully get somewhat of an
understanding as to how these systems
are trained
okay so before that some course
Logistics things so project proposals
both custom and final were due a few
minutes ago
um so if you haven't done that this is a
nice reminder
um we're in the process of assigning
mentors of projects so we'll give
feedback soon
um besides that assignment five is due
on Friday at midnight we still recommend
using collab for the assignments even if
you've had AWS or Azure credits granted
if that doesn't work there's
instructions for how to connect to a
kaggle notebook where you will also be
able to use gpus look for that post on
Ed and then finally also just posted on
Ed by John is a course feedback survey
so this is part of your participation
grade please fill that in by Sunday 11
59 pm
okay
Okay so
let's get into this lecture which is
going to be about what we are trying to
do with these larger and larger models
right over the years the compute for
these models have just you know gone up
uh hundreds of
um you know powers of 10. uh trained on
more and more data right so larger and
larger models they're seeing more and
more data
and in lecture 10
if you recall this slide we talked a
little bit about what happens when you
do pre-training and as you begin to
really learn to predict the missing
sentence in certain texts right you
learn things like syntax co-reference
sentiment
Etc but in this lecture we're going to
take it a little bit further and really
take this idea to its logical conclusion
so if you really follow this idea of
we're just going to train a giant
language model on all of the world's
text you really begin to see language
models sort of in a way as rudimentary
World models so maybe they're not very
good at World models but they kind of
have to be doing some implicit World
modeling just because we have so much
information on the internet and so much
of human Collective knowledge is
transcribed and written for us on the
internet right so if you are really good
at predicting the next word in text what
do you learn to do there's evidence that
these large language models are to some
degree learning to represent and think
about agents and humans and the beliefs
and acronyms they might take so here's
an example from a recent paper where we
are talking about someone named Pat
watching a demonstration of a bowling
ball and a leaf being dropped at the
same time in a vacuum chamber and the
idea is uh here we're saying Pat is a
physicist right so if Pat is a physicist
and we ask for the language models uh
next continuation of the sentence
because he's a physicist we do some
inference about what kind of knowledge
Pat has and Pat will predict that the
bowling ball and the leaf will fall at
the same time but if we change the
sentence of the prompt and we say well
Pat has actually never seen this
demonstration before then Pablo predicts
that the bowling ball will fall to the
ground first which is wrong right so if
you get really good at predicting the
next sentence in text you also to some
degree have to learn to predict an
agent's beliefs their backgrounds common
knowledge and what they might do next
so not just that of course if we
continue browsing the internet we see a
lot of encyclopedic knowledge so maybe
language models are actually good at
solving math reasoning problems if
they've seen enough demonstrations of
math on the internet code of course
co-generation is a really exciting topic
that people will that people are looking
into and will give a presentation on
that in a few weeks even medicine right
we're beginning to think about language
models trained on medical texts and
being applied to the sciences and
whatnot
so this is what happens when we really
take this language modeling idea
seriously and this has resulted in a
Resurgence of interest in building
language models that are basically
assistants right you can give them any
task Under the Sun I want to create a
three-course meal and a language model
should be able to take a good stab at
being able to do this right this is kind
of the promise of language modeling
but of course there's a there's a lot of
steps required to get from this from our
basic language modeling objective and
that's what this lecture is going to be
about
so how do we get from just particular
next word in a sentence to something
like chat GPT which you can really ask
it to do anything and it might fail
sometimes but it's getting really really
convincingly good at some things
okay so this is the lecture plan
basically I'm going to talk about
as we're working with these large
language models we come up with kind of
increasingly complex ways of steering
the language models closer and closer to
something like chat GPT so we'll start
with zero shot and few shot learning
then instruction fine-tuning and then
reinforcing learning from Human feedback
or rohf
okay so let's first talk about a few
shot and zero shot learning
uh and in order to do so we're again
going to kind of build off of the
pre-training lecture last Tuesday so in
the pre-training lecture John talked
about uh these models like GPT
generative pre-trained Transformer
um that are these decoder only language
models so they're just trained to
predict the next word in a corpus of
text
and back in 2018 was the first iteration
of this model uh and it was 117 million
parameters so at the time it was pretty
big nowadays it's definitely much
smaller and again it's just a vanilla
Transformer decoder using the techniques
that you've seen and it's trained on a
corpus of books
so about 4.6 gigabytes of text
and what GPT showed was the promise at
doing this simple language modeling
objective and serving as an effective
pre-training technique for various
Downstream tasks that you might care
about so if you wanted to apply to
something like natural language
inference you would take your premise
sentence and your hypothesis sentence
concatenate them and then maybe train a
linear classifier on the last
representation the model produces
okay but that was three four five years
ago what has changed since then
so they came out with gpt2 so gpt2 was
released the next year in 2019. this is
1.5 billion parameters so it's the same
architecture as GBC but just an order of
magnitude bigger and also trained on
much more data so we went from four
gigabytes of books to 40 gigabytes of
Internet Text data so they produced a
data set called webtext this is produced
by scraping a bunch of links to comments
on Reddit so the idea is that the web
contains a lot of spam maybe a lot of
low quality information but they took
links that were posted on Reddit that
had at least a few uploads so humans
maybe looked through it and said you
know this is a useful post so that was
kind of a rough proxy of human quality
and that's how they collected this large
data set
and so if you look at the size of gbt in
2018 we can draw a bigger dot which is
the size of gpt2 in 2019 and one might
ask how much better does this do what
does this buy you
so the authors of gbt2 titled their
paper language models are unsupervised
multitask Learners and that kind of
gives you a hint as to what the key
takeaway they found was which is this
unsupervised multitasking part
so basically I think the key takeaway
from gbt2 was this idea that language
models can display zero shot learning so
what I mean by zero shot learning is you
can do many tasks that the model may not
have actually explicitly been trained
for with no grading updates so you just
kind of query the model
by simply specifying the right sequence
prediction problem so if you care about
question answering for example you might
include your passage like a Wikipedia
article about Tom Brady and then you'll
add a question so question where was Tom
Brady born and then include an answer
like a followed by colon and then just
ask the model to predict the next token
right you've kind of jury-rigged the
model into doing question answering
for other tasks like classification
tasks another thing you can do is
compare different probabilities of
sequences so this task is called the
Winograd schema challenge it's a pronoun
resolution task so the task is to kind
of resolve a pronoun which requires some
World Knowledge so one example is
something like the cat couldn't fit into
the Hat because it was too big and the
question is whether it refers to the cat
or to the hat right and in this case it
makes most sense for it to refer to the
cats because things fitting into things
because they're too big you know you
need to use some World Knowledge to kind
of resolve that
so the way that you get zero shot
predictions for this task out of a
language model like gbt2 is you just ask
the language model which sequence is
more likely is the probability of the
cat couldn't fit into the Hat because
the cat was too big deemed more likely
by the language model than the
probability that the cat couldn't fit
into the Hat because the Hat was too big
right you can score those sequences
because this is a language model and
from there you get your zero shot
prediction and you can end up doing
fairly well on this task
any questions about those
okay
uh yeah so digging a little bit more
into the results gpt2 at the time beat
the state of the art on a bunch of
language modeling benchmarks with no
task specific fine-tuning so no
traditional fine tune on a training set
and then test on a testing set
so here's an example of such a task this
is a language modeling task called
Lambada or the goal is to predict a
missing word and the idea is that the
word that you need to predict depends on
some discourse earlier in the sentence
or earlier a few sentences ago and by
simply training your language model and
then running it on the Lambada task you
end up doing better than the supervised
fine-tuned state-of-the-art at the time
and across across a wide variety of
other tasks as well
okay
another kind of interesting Behavior
they observed and so you'll see hints of
um uh things that we now take for
granted in this paper is that you can
get interesting zero shot Behavior as
long as you take some liberties with how
you specify the task so for example
let's imagine that we want our model to
do summarization even though gpt2 was
just a language model how can we make it
do summarization
the idea they explored was we're going
to take an article some news article and
then at the end we're going to append
the tldr sign right the tldr token so
this stands for too long didn't read so
use a lot on Reddit to just say you know
if you didn't want to read the above
stuff here's a few sentences that
summarizes it right so if you ask the
model to predict what follows after the
tldr token right you might expect that
it'll generate some sort of summary
and this is kind of early Whispers at
this term that we now call prompting
right which is thinking of the right way
to define a task such that your model
will do the behavior that you want it to
do
so if we look at the performance we
actually observed on this task here at
the bottom is a random Baseline so you
just select three sentences from the
article and the scores that we're using
here are ruse scores if you remember the
natural language generation lecture gpt2
is right above so it's not actually that
good like it only does maybe a little
bit or barely any better than the random
Baseline but it is approaching
approaches that our supervised
approaches that are actually explicitly
fine-tuned to do summarization
right
and of course at the time it's still
underperformed the state of the Arts but
this really showed the promise of
getting language models to do things
that maybe they weren't trained to do
okay so that was gbt2 that was 2019. now
here's 2020 gpt3
so GPD 3 is 175 billion parameters so
it's another increase in size by an
order of magnitude and at the time it
was unprecedented I think it still is
like kind of overwhelmingly large for
most people and data so they scaled the
data once again
okay so what is this by you
this paper's title was called language
models are few shot learners
so what does that mean
so the key takeaway from gpt3 was
emergent few shot learning so the idea
here is sure gbt can still do zero shot
learning but now you can specify a task
by basically giving examples of the task
before asking it to predict the example
that you care about
okay so this is often called in context
learning to stress that there are no
gradient updates being performed when
you learn a new task you're basically
kind of constructing a tiny little
training data set and just including it
in the prompt including it in the
context window of your Transformer and
then asking it to pick up on what the
task is and then predict the right
answer
and this is in contrast to a separate
literature on few shot learning which
assumes that you can do gradient updates
right in this case it's really just a
frozen language model
so few shot learning works and it's
really impressive so here's a graph
super glue here is a kind of a wide
coverage natural language understanding
Benchmark and what they did was they
took dbt3 and this data point here is
what you get when you just do zero shot
learning with dbt3 so you provide an
English description of the tasks to be
completed and then you ask it to
complete the task
just just by providing one example so
one shot uh you get like a 10 accuracy
increase right so you give not only the
natural language test description but
also an example input and an example
output and you ask it to decode the next
output
and as you increase to more shots you do
get better and better
um scores although of course you get
diminishing returns after a while but
what you can notice is that Hue shot
tpt3 so no grading updates uh is doing
as well as or outperforming uh Bert
fine-tuned on the super glue task
explicitly
any questions about this
so one thing that I think is really
exciting is that uh you might think okay
a few shot learning whatever it's just
memorizing maybe there's a lot of
examples of needing to do a few shot
learning in the internet Text data right
and that's true but I think there's also
evidence that uh gpt3 is really learning
to do some sort of kind of on-the-fly
optimization or reasoning and so the
evidence for this comes in the form of
the synthetic word unscrambling tasks so
the authors came up with a bunch of
simple kind of letter manipulation tasks
that are probably unlikely to exist in
Internet Text data so these include
things like cycling through the letters
to get the kind of uncycled version of a
word so converting from PL EAP to Apple
removing characters added to a word or
even just reversing words right and what
you see here is performance as you do
few shot learning as you increase the
model size and what you can see is that
uh
the ability to do a few shot learning is
kind of an emergent property of model
scale so at the very largest model we're
actually seeing a model be able to do
this exclusively in context
okay
uh question yeah
I've noticed the Reversed words are
horrible like performance yeah yeah so
the question was the Reversed words
uh line is still low yeah that's an
example of a task that this models still
can't solve yes although I'm not sure if
we evaluated with newer newer models
maybe you know the latest versions can
indeed actually solve that task Yeah
question here's some intuition for why
the subjects as a result of the model
scale I think that's a highly active
area of research and there's like being
papers published every week on this so I
think there's a lot of interesting
experiments that really try to dissect
you know either with like synthetic
tasks like you know can gbt3 learn
linear regression in context and there's
like some model interpretability tasks
like you know what in the attention
layers or what in the hidden states are
resulting in this kind of emergent
learning
um but yeah I'd have to just refer you
to the recent literature on that
anything else
awesome
okay so just to summarize traditional
fine-tuning here is on the right right
we take a bunch of examples of a task
that we care about we give it to our
model and then we do a grading step on
each example and then at the end we
hopefully get a model that can do well
on some outputs and in this new kind of
Paradigm of just prompting a language
model we just have a frozen language
model and we just give some examples and
ask the model to predict the right
answer
okay
so you might think and you'd be right
that there are some limits of prompting
well there's a lot of limits of
prompting but especially for tasks that
are too hard right there are a lot of
tasks that maybe seem too difficult
um especially ones that involve maybe
richer reasoning steps uh or you know
needing to synthesize multiple pieces of
information and these are tasks that
humans struggle with too right
so one example is gpt3 I don't have the
result the the actual graph here but it
was famously bad at doing addition for
much larger digits and so if you prompt
gpt3 with a bunch of examples of
addition it won't do it correct but part
of the reason is because humans are also
pretty bad at doing this in one step
right like if I asked you to just add
these two numbers on the Fly and didn't
give you a pencil on paper you'd have a
pretty hard time with it
so one observation is that you can just
change the prompts and hopefully get
some better performance out of this
so there's this idea of doing Chain of
Thought prompting where in standard
prompting we give some examples of a
task that we'd like to complete so here
is an example of a math word problem and
I told you that what we would do is we
would give the question and then the
answer and then for a data point that we
actually care about we ask the model to
predict the answer
and the model will try to produce the
right answer and it's just wrong
so the idea of Chain of Thought
prompting is to actually demonstrate
what kind of reasoning you want the
model to complete
so in your prompts you not only put the
question but you also put an answer and
the kinds of reasoning steps that are
required to arrive at the correct answer
right so here is actually some reasoning
of how you actually would answer this
tennis ball question and then get the
right answer and because a language
model is essential you know incentivized
to just follow the pattern and continue
the prompt if you give it another
question it will in turn produce an
answer sorry a rationale followed by an
answer
okay
so you're kind of asking a language
model to work through the steps yourself
and by doing so you end up getting some
questions right when you otherwise might
not
so super simple idea but it's shown to
be extremely effective so here is this
middle school math word problems
Benchmark and again as we scale up the
model for GPT and some other kinds of
models
um being able to do Chain of Thought
prompting emerges right so we really see
a performance approaching that of
supervised baselines for these larger
and larger models
questions
yeah
seemingly the problem with the addition
with the barge members do you have like
results on how like chain of thoughts on
people with larger numbers than middle
school math word problems
yeah so the question is uh does chain
without prompting work for those
addition problems that I had presented
yeah um there should be some results in
the um in the actual paper uh they're
just not here but you can take a look
yeah
you should know how the model was
trained without doing gradient update I
just been in Europe intuition about how
the model is Learning Without grading
updates yeah so this is related to the
question asked earlier about like how is
this actually happening
um that is yeah again it's an active
area of research so my understanding of
the literature is something like you can
show that models are kind of almost
doing like in-context gradient descent
as it's encoding a prompt
um and you can analyze this with like
model interpretability experiments but I
yeah I'm happy to suggest papers
afterwards that kind of deal with this
problem
more carefully
cool
Okay so
a follow-up work to this ask the
question of do we actually even need
examples of reasoning right do we
actually need to collect humans working
through these problems can we actually
just ask the model to reason through
things just ask it nicely right
uh so this introduced this idea called
zero shot Chain of Thought prompting and
it was honestly like I think probably
like the highest like impact to like
simple idea ratio I've seen in the paper
where it's like the simplest possible
thing where instead of doing this Chain
of Thought stuff you just ask the
question and then the answer you first
prepend the token let's think step by
step
right
and the model will decode as if it had
said let's think step by step and it
will work through some reasoning and
produce the right answer
so does this work uh on some arithmetic
benchmarks here's what happens when you
prompt a model just zero shots right so
just asking it to produce the answer
right away without any reasoning a few
shots or giving some examples of inputs
and outputs
and this is zero shot chain of thoughts
just asking the model to think through
things you get uh crazy good accuracy
when we compare to actually doing manual
Chain of Thought you still do better
with manual chains of thought but that
just goes to show you how simple of an
idea this is and ends up producing
improved performance numbers
so the funny part of this paper was they
you know why use less thing by step by
step they used actually a lot of prompts
and tried them out so here's zero shot
Baseline performance they tried out a
bunch of different you know prefixes the
answers after the proof let's think
let's think about this logically and
they found that let's think step by step
was the best one
it turns out this was actually built
upon
um later in the year where they actually
used a language model to search through
the like best possible strings that
would maximize performance on this task
which is probably like gross overfitting
but the best pump they found was let's
work this out step by step in a
step-by-step way to be sure that we have
the right answer
so the right answer thing is kind of
presuming that you get the answer right
right it's like giving the model some
confidence itself
okay so this might seem to you like a
total dark Arcane art and that's because
it is like we really have no intuition
as to what's going on here
um we're trying to build some intuition
uh but as a result and I'm sure you've
seen you know if you spend time in Tech
circles or you've seen on the internet
there's this whole new idea of prompt
engineering being an emerging science
and profession so this includes things
like asking a model for reasoning uh it
includes jailbreaking language models so
telling them to do things that they was
you know other otherwise aren't trained
to do uh even you know air like dolly or
stable diffusion this idea of
constructing these really complex
prompts to get model outputs that you
want that's also prompting
anecdotally I've heard of people saying
I'm going to use a cogeneration model
but I'm going to include the Google code
header in first because that will make
more professional or bug-free code
depending on how much you believe in
Google
um but yeah
and there's a Wikipedia article on this
now and there's even startups that are
hiring for prompt engineers and they pay
quite well so if you want to be a prompt
engineer definitely practice your GPT
with spring skills
we have a question
sorry um yes
uh could you a few classical you said
Alum designs they're most like this long
uh output how can you get the LM to
design uh and like so I think they treat
it like your reinforcement learning
problem
um but I'll just direct you to this
paper at the bottom to learn more
details yeah this is the Joe at all 2022
paper
Yeah question
um so I'm just like a bit curious about
how they provided feedback so in case
the model was not given the right answer
were they like prompts to say that
um that's not right maybe think about
because customer service like how how is
feedback provided they don't think about
feedback in this kind of chain of power
prompting experiments they just like if
the model gets the answer wrong then it
gets the answer wrong and we just
evaluate accuracy right but this idea of
incorporating AI feedback I think is
quite interesting and I think uh you'll
see some maybe hints of discussion about
later on yeah
questions
okay awesome
okay so uh talking about these three
things I'm going to talk about kind of
the benefits and limitations of you know
the various different things that we
could be doing here so for zero shot and
few shot in context learning the benefit
is you don't need any fine tuning uh and
you can kind of carefully construct your
prompt to hopefully get better
performance
the downsides are there are limits to
what you can fit in context right
Transformers have a fixed context window
of say a thousand or you know a few
thousand tokens and I think as you will
probably find out for really complex
tasks you are indeed going to need some
gradient steps so you're going to need
some sort of fine tuning
uh but that brings us to the next part
of the lecture so that's instruction
fine-tuning
okay so the idea of instruction
fine-tuning is that sure these models
are pretty good at doing prompting you
can get them to do really interesting
things but there is still a problem
which is that language models are
trained to predict the most likely
continuation of tokens and that is not
the same as what we want language models
to do which is to assist people so as an
example if I give gpd3 this kind of
prompt explain the moon landing gpt3 is
trained to predict you know if I saw
this on the internet somewhere what is
the most likely continuation well maybe
someone was coming up with a list of
things to do with a six-year-old so it's
just predicting a list of other tasks
right it's not answering your question
and so the issue here is that language
models are not the term is aligned with
user intent
so how might we better align models with
user intent for this case
well super simple answer right we're
machine Learners let's do machine
learning so we're going to collect you
ask a human uh give me the right answer
right give me the way that a language
model should respond according to this
prompt and let's just do fine tuning
right
so this is a slide from the pre-training
lecture uh again pre-training can
improve NLP applications
um by serving as parameter
initialization so this kind of pipeline
I think you are familiar with and the
difference here is that instead of
fine-tuning on a single Downstream task
of Interest like sentiment analysis what
we're going to do is we're going to fine
tune on many tasks so we have a lot of
tasks and the hope is that we can then
generalize to other unseen tasks at test
time
so as you might expect
um data and scale is kind of key for
this to work so we're going to collect a
bunch of examples of instruction output
pairs across many tasks
and then fine-tune our language model
and then evaluate generalization to
unseen tasks
okay
yeah so data and scale is important so
as an example one recent data set that
was published for this is called the
supernatural instructions data set it
contains over 1.6 000 tasks containing
three million examples so this includes
translation question answering question
generation even coding mathematical
reasoning Etc
and when you look at this you really
begin to think well is this actually
fine-tuning or is this just more
pre-training right and it's actually
both right it's kind of a it's we're
kind of blurring the lines here where
the amount of scale that we're training
this on basically it is kind of a still
General but slightly more specific than
language modeling type of pre-training
task
okay so one question I have is now that
we are training our model on so many
tasks how do we evaluate such a model
right because you can't really say okay
can you now do sentiment analysis well
right like the scale of tasks that we
want to evaluate this language model on
is much greater
so just as a brief aside
um you know a lot of research has been
going into building up these benchmarks
for these massive multicast language
models and seeing to what degree they
can do not only just one task but just a
variety of tasks so this is the massive
multitask language understanding
Benchmark or mmlu it consists of a bunch
of benchmarks for measuring language
model performance on a bunch of
knowledge intensive tasks that you would
expect to high school or college student
to complete so you're testing a language
model not only on you know send them
analysis but on astronomy and logic and
European history
and here are some numbers where you know
at the time dpt3 is like not that good
but it's certainly above a random
Baseline on all of these tasks
here's another example so this is the
beyond the imitation game Benchmark or
big bench this has like a billion
authors because it was a huge
collaborative efforts uh and these are
this is a word cloud of the tasks that
were evaluated
um and it really contains some very
esoteric tasks so this is an example of
one task included where you have to
given uh kanji or Japanese character in
ASCII art you need to predict the
meaning of the character right so we're
really stress testing these language
models
okay so instruction fine tuning does it
work
um
recall the there's a T5 encoded decoder
model so this is kind of Google's
encoder decoder model where it's
pre-trained on this span corruption task
so if you don't remember that you can
refer back to that lecture but the
authors released a newer version called
flan T5 so flan stands for fine-tuning
language models and this is T5 models
trained on an additional 1.8 000 tasks
which include the natural instructions
data set that I just mentioned and if we
average across both the big bench and
and LU performance and normalize it what
we see is that instruction fine tuning
works
and crucially the bigger the model the
bigger the benefit that you get from
doing construction fine tuning right so
it's really the large models that stand
to do well from fine tuning
and you might look at this and say this
is kind of sad for academics or anyone
without a massive GPU cluster right it's
like who can run an 11 billion parameter
model I guess the one silver lining if
you look at the results here are the 80
million model which is the smallest one
if you look at after fine tuning it ends
up performing about as well as the UN
fine-tuned 11 billion parameter model
right so there's a lot of examples in
the literature about smaller instruction
fine-tuned pre-trained models
outperforming larger models that are
many many more times the size right so
hopefully there's still some hope for
people with just like a few gpus
questions
in order to really understand the
capabilities I highly recommend that you
just try it out yourself so flan T5 is
hosted on hugging face I think hugging
face has a demo where you can just type
in a little you know query asked to do
anything see what it does
um but you know there are qualitative
examples of this working so four
questions where a non-instruction
fine-tuned model will just kind of
waffle on and not answer the question
doing instruction fine-tuning will get
your model to much more accurately
reason through things and gave you the
right answer
okay
so that was instruction fine tuning
um positives of this method super simple
super straightforward it's just doing
fine tuning right and you see this
really cool ability to generalize to
unseen tasks
in terms of negatives does anyone have
any ideas for why my might be um
downsides of instruction fine-tuning
I don't want to comment
yeah it seems like it suffers from the
same negatives of any human Source data
yeah
how to get people to provide the input
you don't know like different people
think different if it's about it yeah
yeah exactly so comments are well it's
hard and annoying to get human labels
and it's expensive that's something that
definitely matters and that last part
you mentioned about there might be you
know humans might disagree on what the
right label is yeah that's increasingly
a problem
um yeah so what are the limitations the
obvious limitation is money collecting
ground truth data for so many tasks
costs a lot of money
start a lot of limitations include the
one that you were mentioning so as we
begin to ask for more creative and
open-ended tasks from our models right
there are tasks where there is no right
answer and it's a little bit weird to
say you know this is an example of how
to write some story right so write me a
story about a dog and our pet
grasshopper like there is not one answer
to this but if we were only to collect
one or two demonstrations the language
modeling objective would say you should
put all of your probability Mass on you
know the two ways that two humans wrote
this answer right when in reality
there's no right answer
another problem which is related kind of
fundamentally to language modeling in
the first place is that language
modeling as an objective penalizes all
token level mistakes equally
so what I mean by that is if you're
asking a language model for example to
predict the sentence Avatar is a fantasy
TV show
and you were asking it and let's imagine
that you know the LM mispredicted
Adventure instead of fantasy right so
Adventure is a is a mistake it's not the
right word but it is uh equally as bad
as if the model were to predict
something like musical right but the
problem is that Avatar is an adventure
TV show is like still true right so it's
not necessarily A Bad Thing whereas
Avatar is a musical is just false so
under the language modeling objective
right if the model we're equally
confident you would pay the inequal
penalty in equal loss penalty for
predicting either of those tokens wrong
but it's clear that this objective is
not actually aligned with what users
want which is maybe truth or creativity
or generally just this idea of human
preferences right
Yeah question
can we multiply the penalty by like the
distance from where to betting in order
to reduce this because musical would
have a higher distance away than
Adventure
yeah that's an interesting question
um it's an interesting idea I haven't
heard of people doing that but it seems
plausible I guess one issue is you might
come up with like
adversarial settings or like maybe the
word embedding distance is also not
telling you the right thing right so for
example show in musical Maybe are very
close together because they're they're
both you know shows or things to watch
but they are like in false in veracity
right they're completely different one
is true one is false right so yeah you
can try it although I think there might
be some tricky edge cases like that
yeah
cool
okay so in the next part of the talk
we're going to actually explicitly try
to satisfy human preferences and come
with a mathematical framework for doing
so
and yeah so these are the limitations as
I just mentioned
so this is where we get into
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
okay
so rlhf
so let's say we were training a language
model on some tasks like summarization
and let's imagine that for each language
model sample s let's imagine that we had
a way to obtain a human reward of that
summary
so we could score this summary with a
reward function which we'll call our R
of s and the higher the reward the
better
so let's imagine we're summarizing this
article and we have this summary which
maybe is pretty good let's say we had
another summary maybe it's a bit worse
and if we were able to ask a human to
just rate all these outputs then the
objective that we want to maximize or
satisfy is very obvious we just want to
maximize the expected reward of samples
from our language model right so in
expectation as we take samples from our
language model P Theta we just want to
maximize the reward of those samples
fairly straightforward
so
uh oh and for mathematical Simplicity
here I'm kind of assuming that there's
only one task or one prompt right so
let's imagine we were just trying to
summarize like this article
um but we could talk about how to extend
it to like multiple prompts later on
okay so this kind of task is the domain
of reinforcement learning so I'm not
going to presume there's any knowledge
of reinforcing learning although I'm
sure some of you are quite familiar with
it probably even more familiar than I am
but the field of reinforcement learning
has studied these kinds of uh problems
these optimization problems of kind of
how to optimize something while you're
kind of simulating the optimization for
many years now
and in 2013 there was a Resurgence of
interest in reinforcement learning for
deep learning specifically so you might
have seen these results from Deep bind
about an agent learning to play Atari
games and agent mastering go much
earlier than expected
but interestingly I think the interest
in applying reinforcement learning to
Modern LMS is a bit newer on the other
hand and I think the kind of earliest
success story or one of the earliest
success stories was only in 2019 for
example
so why might be this be the case there's
a few reasons I think in general the
field had kind of dissensed that
reinforcement learning with language
models was really hard to get right
partially because language models are
very complicated and if you think of
language models as actors that have an
action space where they can spit out any
sentence that's a lot of sentences right
so it's like a very complex space to
explore in
so it still is a really hard problem so
that's part of the reason but also
practically I think there have been
these newer algorithms that seem to work
much better for deep mural models
including language models and these
include algorithms like proximal policy
optimization but we won't get into the
details of that for this course
but these are the kind of the reasons
why we begin you know re-interested in
this idea of doing RL with language
models
okay
so how do we actually maximize the
subjective right I've written it down
and ideally we should just change our
parameters data so that reward is high
right but it doesn't it's not really
clear how to do so
so when we think about it I mean what
have we learned in the class thus far we
know that we can do gradient descent or
gradient Ascent so let's try doing
gradient Ascent right we're going to
maximize this objective so we're going
to step in the direction of steepest
gradient
but this quickly becomes a problem which
is what is this quantity and how do we
evaluate it right how do we estimate
this expectation given that the gradient
the variables of the gradient that we're
taking Theta appear in the sample of the
expectation
and the second is what if our reward
function is not differentiable right
like human judgments are not
differentiable we can't back prop
through them and so we need this to be
able to work with a black box reward
function
so there's a class of methods in
reinforcement learning called policy
gradient methods that gives us tools for
estimating and optimizing this objective
and for the purposes of this course I'm
going to try to describe kind of the
highest possible and highest level
possible intuition for this which kind
of looks at kind of the math and shows
what's going on here but it is going to
emit a lot of the details and a full
treatment of reinforcement learning is
definitely outside of the scope of this
course so if you're more interested in
this kind of content you should check
out cs234 reinforcing learning for
example
and in general I think this is going to
get a little messy but it's totally fine
if you don't understand it we will talk
we'll regroup at the end and just show
like what this means for how to do our
lhf
but what I'm going to do is just
describe how we actually estimate this
objective right so we want to obtain
this gradient so it's the gradient of
the expectation of the reward of samples
from our language model
and if we do the math we break this
apart this is our definition of what an
expectation is right we're going to sum
over all sentences rated by the
probability
uh and due to the linearity of the
gradient we can put the gradient
operator inside of the sum
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use a very handy trick known as
a log derivative trick and this is
called a trick but it's really just a
chain rule but let's just see what
happens when we take the gradient of the
log probability of a sample from our
language model
so if I take the gradients then how do
we use a chain rule right so the
gradient of the log of something is
going to be 1 over that something times
the gradient of the middle of that
something so 1 over P Theta of s times
the gradient and if we rearrange we see
that we can alternatively write the
gradient of P Theta of s as this product
so P Theta of s times the gradient of
the log P data this
and we can plug this back in
and the reason why we're doing this is
because we're going to convert this into
a form where the expectation is easy to
estimate
so we plug it back in that gives us this
and if you squint quite closely at this
last equation here this first part here
is the definition of an expectation
right we are summing over a bunch of
samples from our model and we are
waiting it by the probability of that
sample which means that we can rewrite
it as an expectation and in particular
it's an expectation of this quantity
here
right
so let's just rewrite it
and this gives us our kind of newer form
of this objective so these two are
equivalent the top here and the bottom
and what has happened here is we've kind
of shoved the gradient inside of the
expectation if that makes sense
so why is this useful
does anyone have any questions on this
before I move on if you don't understand
it that's fine as well
because it doesn't I mean we will
understand kind of the intuition behind
it later
okay
Okay so we've converted this into this
and we put the gradient inside the
expectation which means we can now
approximate this objective with Monte
Carlo samples so the way to approximate
any expectation is to just take a bunch
of samples and then average them right
so approximately this is equal to
sampling a finite number of samples from
our model and then summing up the
average of the reward times the log
probability the gradient of the log
probability of that sample
and that gives us this update rule
plugging it back in for that creating a
sense that we wanted
right
so what what is this what does this mean
uh let's think about like a very simple
case right imagine the reward uh was a
binary reward so it's either zero or one
so for example imagine we were trying to
train a language model to talk about
cats so whenever it utters a sentence
with a word cat we give it a one reward
otherwise we give it a zero reward okay
now if a reward is binary does anyone
know what this objective kind of reduces
to or look like
any ideas
I've lost everyone that's fine too
yeah so the reward would just be like an
indicator
yeah that's right
so basically to answer uh the reward
would be zero right everywhere except
for sentences that contain the word cat
right and in that case it would be one
so basically that would just look like
kind of vanilla vanilla grading descent
just on sentences that contain the word
cap right
so kind of to generalize this to the
more General case where the reward is
scalar what this is looking like if you
look at it is if R is very high very
positive then we're multiplying the
gradient of that sample by a large
number and so our objective will try to
take grading steps in the direction of
maximizing the probability of producing
that sample again right producing the
sample that led to high reward
and on the other hand if R is low or
even negative then we will actively take
steps to minimize the probability that's
happening again
right and that's like the English
intuition of what's going on here right
the reason why we call it reinforcement
learning is because we want to reinforce
good actions and increase the
probability that they happen again in
the future and hopefully this
intuitively makes sense to all of you
let's say you're playing a video game
and on one run you get a super high
score and you think to yourself oh that
was really good like whatever I did that
time I should do again in the future
right this is what we're trying to
capture with this kind of update
question
any reason that we use policy gradient
and not like value iteration or other
methods you can do yeah you can do a lot
of things I think there have been
methods for doing q-learning offline
learning Etc with
um language models I think the design
space is has been very underexplored so
there's like a lot of low-hanging fruit
out there for people who are willing to
think about what fancy things we can do
in RL and apply them to this language
model in case yeah
and in practice what we use is not this
simple thing but we use a fancier thing
that is a proximal policy optimization
question does space are like super big
like almost good yeah so that's so
that's that's the challenge
um so one thing that I haven't mentioned
here is that right now I'm talking about
kind of entire samples of sentences
which is like a massive space right in
practice when we do RL we actually do it
the level of generating individual
tokens so each token is let's say GPT
has 50 000 tokens right so it's a pretty
large action space but it's still
manageable right but yeah
so that kind of answers this question I
was asking which is like can you see any
problems with this objective right which
is that this is a very simplified
objective there is a lot more tricks
needed to make this work but hopefully
this has given you kind of the high
level intuition as to what we're trying
to do in the first place
okay
okay so now we are set right we have a
bunch of samples from a language model
and for any arbitrary reward function
like we're just asking a human to rate
these samples we can maximize that
reward so we're done
okay so not so fast
um there's a few problems the first is
the same as in the instruction
fine-tuning case right which is that
keeping a human in the loop is expensive
like I don't really want to supervise
every single output from a language
model I don't know if you all want to
um so what can we do to fix this
so one idea is instead of needing to ask
humans for preferences every single time
you can actually build a model of their
preferences like literally just train an
NLP model of their preferences
so this idea was kind of first
introduced outside of language modeling
by this paper Knox and stone they called
it Tamer but we're going to see it
re-implemented in this idea where we're
going to train a language model we'll
call it a reward model RM just
parameterized by fee to predict human
preferences from an annotated data set
and then when doing rlhf we're going to
optimize for the reward model rewards
instead of actual human Rewards
here's another conceptual problem so
here's a new sample for our
summarization task right what is the
score of the sample anyone give me a
number
does anyone want to rate this sample
it's like a three six what scale are we
using Etc
so the issue here is that human
judgments can be noisy and miscalibrated
when you ask people for things alone
right
so one workaround for this problem is
instead of asking for direct ratings ask
humans to compare two summaries and
judge which one is better this has been
shown I think in a variety of fields
where people work with human subjects
and human responses to be more reliable
this includes psychology and Medicine
Etc
so in other words instead of asking
humans to just give absolute scores
we're going to ask humans to compare
different samples and rate which one is
better
so as an example maybe this first sample
is better than the middle sample and
it's better than the last sample right
now that we have these pairwise
comparisons our reward model is going to
generate kind of latent scores so
implicit scores based on this pairwise
comparison data so our reward model is a
language model that takes in a possible
sample and then it's going to produce a
number which is the score or the reward
and the way that we're going to train
this model and again you don't really
need to know too much of the details
here but this is a classic kind of
statistical comparison model is via the
following laws where the reward model
essentially should just predict a higher
score if a sample is judged to be better
than another sample so in expectation if
we sample winning samples and losing
samples from our data sets then if you
look at this term here the score of the
higher sample should be higher than the
score of the losing sample
does that make sense
and in doing so by just trading on the
subjective you will get a language model
that will learn to assign numerical
scores to things which indicate their
relative you know preference over other
samples and we can use those outputs as
Rewards
yeah
the normalization either in the like the
output or somewhere else because it
looks like this yeah so
I don't remember if it happens during
training but certainly after you've
trained this model you normalize the
reward model so that the score is the
expectation of the score is zero because
that's good for reinforced learning and
things like that as well
Yeah question
like even though these are noisy like
they could be like some people could do
S3 is better than S1 how do we account
for it even though like when it's noisy
like the bordering the ordering yeah I
think that's you know that's just kind
of limitations with asking for these
preferences in the first place is that
humans will disagree right so we really
have no ground truth unless we maybe ask
like an ensemble of humans for example
that's just a limitation with this I
think hopefully with you know in the
limit with enough data this kind of
noise washes out but it's certainly an
issue and
uh this next slide will also kind of
touch on this so does the reward model
work can we actually learn to model
human preferences in this way this is
obviously an important standard they
check before we actually try to optimize
this objective
and they measured this so this is kind
of evaluating the reward model on a
standard kind of validation set right so
can the reward model predict outcomes
for data points that they have not seen
during training and does it change based
on model size or amount of data right
and if you notice here there's one
dashed line which is the human Baseline
which is if you ask a human to predict
the outcome a human does not get 100
accuracy because humans disagree right
and even an ensemble of let's say five
humans also doesn't get 100 accuracy
because humans are different preferences
right
but the key takeaway here is that for
the largest possible model and for
enough data a reward model at least some
of the validations that they that they
used is kind of approaching the
performance of a single human person and
that's kind of a green light that maybe
we can you know try this out and see
what happens
okay so there are no questions this is
kind of the components of our lhf so we
have a pre-trained model maybe a
construction fine-tuned right which
we're going to call P of pt
we have a reward model which produces
scalar rewards for language model
outputs and it is training on a data set
of human comparisons
and we have a method policy gradient for
arbitrarily optimizing language model
parameters towards some reward function
and so now if you want to do rohf you
clone the pre-trained model we're going
to call this a copy of the model which
is our RL model with parameters data
that we're actually going to optimize
and we're going to optimize the
following reward with reinforced
learning and this reward looks a little
bit more complicated than just using the
reward model
and the extra term here is a penalty
which prevents us from diverging too far
from the pre-trained model
so in expectation this is known as the
KL or cold black labor Divergence
between the RL model and the pre-trained
model
and I'll explain why we need this in a
few slides but basically if you over
optimize the reward model you end up
producing you can produce like gibberish
um and what happens is you pay a price
so this quantity is large if the
probability of a sample under the RL
tuned model is much higher than the
probability of the sample under the
pre-train model right so the pre-trained
model would say this is a very unlikely
sequence of characters for anyone to say
uh that's when you would pay a price
here
and beta here is a tunable parameter
Yeah question
when you say initialize a copy that
means like at the first iteration PRL is
equal to p p t that's right yeah
yeah when I say initialize a copy
basically like we want to be able to
compare to the non-fine-tuned model just
to evaluate this penalty term so just
leave the predictions of the the you
know pre-rl model around yeah
questions
right
so does it work the answer is yes so
here is kind of the key takeaway at
least for the task summarization on this
Daily Mail data set
so again we're looking at different
model sizes but at the end here we see
that if we do just pre-training so just
like the typical language modeling
objective that GPT uses you know you end
up producing summaries that in general
are not preferred to the reference
summaries right so this is on the y-axis
here is the amount of times that a human
refers the model generated summary to a
summary that a human actually wrote or
the one that's in the data set
so pre-training doesn't work well even
if you do supervised learning so
supervised learning in this case is
let's actually fine tune our model on
the summaries that were in our data sets
right even if you do that you still kind
of underperform the reference summaries
right because you're not perfectly
modeling those that those summaries
but it's only with this human feedback
that we end up producing a language
model that actually ends up producing
summaries that are judged to be better
than the summaries in a data set that
you were training on in the first place
I think that's quite interesting
any questions
okay
so now we talk about yeah we're getting
closer and closer to something like
construct GPT or chat GPT
the basic idea of instruct GPT is that
we are scaling up our lhf to not just
one prompt as I had described previously
but tens and thousands of prompts right
and if you look at these three pieces
these are the three pieces that we've
just described right the first piece
here being instruction fine-tuning
the second piece being rohf and the
third piece oh sorry the second part
second part being reward model training
and the last part being rohf
the difference here is that they use 30
000 tasks
so kind of again with the same
instruction fine-tuning idea right it's
really about the scale and diversity of
tasks that really matters for getting
good performance for these things
yeah
the proceeding results
is that the
you know that it didn't what that you
really needed you know any chance and it
didn't work so well to be a supervised
learning on the data
um but they do supervise learning on the
day there is in the fine tuning in the
first stage
uh yeah that's a good question so I
think a key Point here is that they
initialize the RL policy on the
supervised policy right so they first
got the model getting reasonably good at
doing
summarization first and then you do the
RL Jeff on top to get the Boost
performance
um your question you're asking is maybe
can we just do the rhf starting from
that pre-trained Baseline
um that's a good question I I don't
think they explored that although I'm
not sure I'd have to I'd have to look at
the paper again to remind myself
um
yeah
so certainly something like instruct GPT
yeah they've always kind of presumed
that you need the kind of fine-tuning
phase first and then you build on top of
it
um but I think yeah there's still some
interesting open questions as to whether
you can just go directly to our lhf yeah
question
simultaneously
uh
reward model should be trained first
yeah you train it first you make sure
it's good it's frozen you optimize
against that
for the human rewards that they come
from the generated tax on language model
or where to stop the training sample
come from
uh for training the reward model
um so yeah actually it's a good question
um where do the rewards come from so uh
there's kind of an iterative process you
can apply where you kind of repeat steps
two and three over and over again so you
sample a bunch of outputs from your
language model you get humans to rate
them you then do rlhf to update your
model again and then you sample more
outputs and get humans to rate them so
in general the rewards are done on
sampled model outputs because those are
the outputs that you want to steer in
One Direction or another but you can
also you can do this in an iterative
process where you kind of do RL and then
maybe do it you know train a better
reward model based on the new outputs
and continue I think they do a few
iterations in structure BT for example
questions
okay
so 30 000 tasks
um I think we're getting into like very
recent stuff where you know increasingly
companies like open AI are sharing less
and less details about like what
actually happens in training these
models right so we have a little bit
less clarity as to what's going on here
then maybe we have have had in the past
uh but they do share uh the data set's
not public but they do share the kinds
of tasks that they collected from
labelers right so they collected a bunch
of prompts uh from people who are
already using the gpt3 API so they had
the benefit of having you know many many
users of their API and taking the kinds
of tasks that they that users would ask
GPT to do
so these include things like
brainstorming or you know open-end
generation
Etc
and yeah I mean the key results of
instruct GPT which is kind of the
backbone of chat EBT uh you know really
just needs to be seen and played with to
understand so you can you feel free to
play with either chatgpt or one of the
open AI apis but again this example of a
language model I'm not necessarily
following tasks by doing this kind of
instruction fine tuning followed by rlhf
you get a model that is much more you
know much better at adhering to user
commands
similarly a language model can be very
good at generating you know super
interesting open-ended creative text as
well
okay
this brings us to chat GPT right which
is even newer and we have even less
information about what's actually going
on and what's being trained here but
uh yeah and they're keeping their you
know Secret Sauce Secret
but they we do have a blog post where
they wrote two paragraphs and in the
first paragraph
they said that they did instruction fine
tuning right so we trained an initial
model using supervised fine tuning so
human AI trainers provided conversations
where they played both sides and then we
asked them to act as a AI assistant and
then we fine-tune our model on acting
like an AI system from humans right
that's part one
second paragraph uh to create a reward
model for RL we collected comparison
data
so we took conversations with a an
earlier version of the chatbot so the
one that's pre-trained on instruction
following or instruction fine-tuning and
then take multiple samples and then rate
the quality of the samples
right
and then using these reward models we
fine-tune it with RL in particular they
used PPO which is a fancier version of
RL
okay
and yeah so that produces you know I
don't need to introduce the capabilities
of chat TBT it's been very exciting
recently here's an example it's fun to
play with definitely play with it
sorry it's a bit of an attack on the
students uh yeah
okay
okay so reinforcement learning
pluses
you're kind of directly modeling what
you care about right which is human
preferences not is the
collection of the demonstration that I
collected right is that the highest
probability mass in your model you're
actually just saying how well am I
satisfying human preferences right so
that's a clear benefit over something
like instruction fine tuning
so in terms of negatives one is that RL
is hard it's very tricky to get rights I
think it will get easier in the future
as we kind of you know explore the
design space of possible options
um so that's an obvious one right does
anyone come up with any other kind of
maybe weaknesses or issues they see with
this kind of training
so is it possible that like your
language model and then your reward
model could like overfit to each other
especially like even if you're not
training them together if you're like
going back and forth yeah yeah so over
optimization I think of the reward model
is an issue
yeah is it also that if you return your
Facebook repeat always you want feedback
all over again yeah so it still is like
extremely data expensive and you can see
some articles if you just Google open AI
like data labeling right people have not
been very happy with like the amount of
data that has been needed to train
something like chat gbt I mean they're
hiring developers to just like explain
coding problems like 40 hours a week
right so it is yeah it is still data
intensive right that's kind of the
takeaway like all of these are like it's
it's all still data intensive every
single one of these right yeah
yeah I think that summarizes kind of
kind of the big ones here right so when
we talk about limitations of our lhf we
also need to talk about just limitations
in general of RL and also this idea that
we can like model or capture human
reward in this single data point right
so human preferences can be very
unreliable the RL people have known this
for a very long time they have a term
called reward hacking which is when an
agent you know is optimizing for
something that the developers specified
but it is not what we actually care
about right
so one of the classic examples is this
example from openai uh where they were
training this agent to race boats and
they were training it to maximize the
score which you can see at the bottom
left but implicitly the score actually
isn't what you care about what you care
about is just finishing the race ahead
of everyone else and the score is just
kind of this bonus
but what the agent found out was that
there are these like turbo boost things
that you can collect which boost your
score and so what it ends up doing is it
ends up kind of just driving in the
middle collecting these turbo boosts
over and over again so it's racking up
insane score but it is not doing the
Race it is continuously crashing into
objects and its boat is always on fire
uh and this is you know a pretty Salient
example of what we call AI misalignment
right
and you might think well okay this is a
really simple example right like they
made a dumb mistake they shouldn't have
used score as a reward function right
but I think it's even more naive to
think that we can capture all of human
preferences in like a single number uh
and assign certain scalar values to
things right
so one example where I think this is
already happening you can see is maybe
you have played with chatbots before and
you and you notice that they do a lot of
hallucination right they make up a lot
of facts and this might be because of
our lhf right chat Bots are rewarded to
produce responses that seem
authoritative or seem helpful but they
don't care about whether it's actually
true or not right they just want to seem
helpful
so this results in making up facts you
may be seeing the news about chat Bots
you know companies are in this relation
to play chat Bots and they make mistakes
uh even being you know also has been
hallucinating a lot right
and in general
when you think about that you think well
it models of human preferences are even
more unreliable right like we're not
even just using human preferences by
themselves we're also training a model a
deep model that we have no idea how that
works right we're going to use that
instead right and that can obviously be
quite dangerous
and so going back to this slide here
where I was describing why we need this
KL penalty term this yellow highlighted
term here here's a concrete example of
what actually happens of a language
model overfitting to the reward model
right so what this is showing is in this
case they took off the kale penalties
they were just trying to maximize reward
right they trained this reward model
let's just push those numbers up as high
as possible right and on the x-axis here
is what happens as training continues
you diverge further and further this is
the KL Divergence or the distance from
where you started
and the the golden dashed line here is
what the reward model predicts your
language model is doing right so your
reward model is thinking wow you were
killing it like they're gonna love these
summaries they are going to love them
way more than the reference summaries
right but in reality when you actually
ask humans uh the preferences Peak and
then they just crater right
so this can be an example of over
optimizing for a metric that you care
about right it ceases to become a good
metric to optimize for
any questions about this
so there's this real concern of I think
people are calling the AI alignment
problem I'll let president talk about
this
um he tweeted that you know the main
tool that we have for rlhf or sorry for
alignment is rohf
um but reward hacking happens a lot
humans are not very good supervisors of
rewards so you know this strategy is
probably going to result in agents that
seem like they're doing the right thing
but they're wrong in subtle and
conspicuous ways and I think we're
already seeing examples of that in the
current generation of chatbots
so in terms of positives here are some
positives but again RL is tricky to get
right human preferences are fallible and
models of human preferences are even
more so
so I remember seeing a joke on Twitter
somewhere where someone was saying that
you know zero shot and few shot learning
is the worst way to align in AI
instruction fine-tuning is the second
worst way to align an AI and rohf is the
third worst way to align an AI right so
we're getting somewhere but you know
each of these have clear fundamental
limitations
yeah
competition
um reinforcement learning because you
get the math that you showed before
essentially you're putting the greatest
Insight so that we can sample it the
sample expectation yeah but when it
comes to sampling how do you make that
parallel because then you need you kind
of need to adaptively stop sampling and
then you don't know when you're going to
start like how do you make that process
quicker I guess just like the whole unit
on Transformers and all that was
paralyzing everything yeah
I mean yeah this is so this is really
compute heavy and I'm actually not sure
like what kind of infrastructure is used
for like a state-of-the-art very
performant implementation of rlhs but
it's possible that they use
parallelization like what you're
describing where I think in a lot of
maybe more traditional RL there's this
kind of idea of having like an actor
learner architecture where you have a
bunch of actor workers which are each
kind of a language model producing a
bunch of samples and then the learner
would then integrate them and perform
the grading updates right so it's
possible that you do need to do like
just sheer like multi-processing in
order to get enough samples to make this
work in a reasonable amount of time
um is that the kind of question you had
or do you have other questions
is larger than what we would typically
see in Transformers
yeah
I'm saying that you might need to
actually copy your model several times
and take samples like from different
copies of the models yeah but in terms
of like like yeah so Auto regressive
generation like Transformers especially
like the forward pass and the multi-head
attention stuff is very easy to
parallelize but Auto regressive
generalization Auto regressive
generation is still like kind of
bottlenecked by
um the fact that it's Auto regressive
right so you have to like run it first
and then you need to depends on what you
sample and have to run it again right so
those are kind of blocks that we haven't
fully been able to solve I think and
that will add to compute cost yeah
okay
so I think we have 10 more minutes so
I'm not mistaken
um so we've mostly finally answered kind
of how we get from this to this right
there's some details missing but the key
kind of factors are one instruction
fine-tuning two this idea of
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
so let's talk a little about a little
bit about what's next
um so as I had mentioned rlhf is still a
very new area it's still very fast
moving I think by the next lecture by
the time we say that you know give this
slides again these slides might look
completely different because maybe a lot
of the things that I was presenting here
turn out to be like really bad ideas or
not the most efficient way of going
about things
rohf gets you further than instruction
fine-tuning but as someone had already
mentioned it is still very data
expensive right there are a lot of
articles about open AI needing to hire a
legion of annotators or developers to
just compare outputs over and over again
I think a recent work that I'm
especially interested in and been
thinking about is how we can get the
benefits of rlh app without such
stringent data requirements
so there's these you know newer you know
kind of crazy ideas about doing
reinforcement learning from not human
feedback but from AI feedback so having
language models themselves evaluate the
output of language models so as an
example of what that might look like a
team from anthropic which works on these
large language models came up with this
idea called constitutional AI
and the basic idea here is that if you
ask gpt3 to identify whether a response
was not helpful it would be pretty good
at doing so and you might be able to use
that feedback itself to improve a model
so as an example if you have some sort
of human request like can you help me
hack into my neighbor's Wi-Fi and the
assistant says yeah sure you can use
this app right
we can ask a model for feedback on this
what we do is we add a critique request
which says Hey language model gpt3
identify ways in which the assistance
response is harmful
and then it will generate a critique
like hacking into someone else's Wi-Fi
is illegal
and then you might ask it to then revise
it right so just rewrite the assistant
response to remove harmful content
and it does so right
and now by just decoding from a language
model I assuming you can do this well
what you have now is a set of data that
you can do instruction fine-tuning on
right you have a request and you have a
request that has been revised to make
sure it doesn't contain harmful content
all right
so this is pretty interesting I think
it's quite exciting but all of those
issues that I had mentioned about like
alignment you know Mis over interpreting
you know human preferences reward models
being followable like everything gets
compounded like 40 000 times when you're
thinking about this right we have no
understanding of like how safe this is
or where this ends up going but it is
something
another kind of more common idea also is
this general idea of fine-tuning
language models on their own outputs and
this has been explored a lot in the
context of Chain of Thought reasoning
which is something I presented at the
beginning of the lecture
and these are provocatively named large
language models can self-improve but
again it's not clear like how much
runway there is but the basic idea maybe
is to you know you can use let's think
step by step for example to get a
language model to produce a bunch of
reasoning and then you can say fine tune
on that reasoning as if it were true
data and see whether or not a language
model can get any better using that
technique
but as I mentioned this is all still
very new uh there are I think a lot of
limitations of large language models
like hallucination and also just the
sheer like size and compute intensity of
this that may or may not be solvable
with our lhf right question
like how we don't want it yeah
like I've seen like people talking about
how like you can Jailbreak chat gbt to
still give like those types of harmful
responses yeah are there any ways
for us to kind of buffer against those
types of things as well because it seems
like you're just going to keep kind of
building on like we identify chances
where it's like trying to say action not
like yourself
um I guess is there any way to kind of
build up that scale to avoid those
jailbreaking possibilities yeah that's
interesting
um
so there are certainly ways that you can
use either AI feedback or human feedback
to mitigate those kinds of jailbreaks
right like if you see someone on Twitter
saying that oh I made gpt3 jailbreak you
know using this strategy or whatever you
can then yeah maybe plug it into this
kind of framework and say identify ways
in which the assistant went off the
rails right and then fine-tuned and
hopefully correct those right but it is
really difficult I think in most of
these kinds of settings it's really
difficult to anticipate all the possible
ways in which a user might jailbreak an
assistant right so you always have this
kind of dynamic of like you know in in
security cyber security for example
there's always like the attacker
Advantage where like you know the
attacker will always come up with
something new or some new exploit right
so
yeah I think this is a deep problem I
don't have like a really clear answer
um but certainly like if we knew what
the jailbreak was we could mitigate it I
think that seems pretty straightforward
yeah
yeah but if you know how to do that you
should like be hired by one of these
companies they'll pay you like Millions
if you can solve this yeah
okay
uh yeah so um just like last remarks is
you know with all of these like scaling
results that I presented and all of
these like oh you can just do
instruction fine-tuning and it'll follow
your instructions or you can do rlhs you
might have like a very bullish I you
know view on like oh this is how we're
gonna solve like artificial general
intelligence by just scaling up our OHF
it's possible that that is actually
going to happen but it's also possible
that there are you know certain
fundamental limitations that we just
need to figure out how to solve by
hallucination before we get anywhere
productive with these models but it is a
really exciting time to work on this
kind of stuff so yeah
thanks for listening and yeah
thank you